malgré la retraite jacques goût continue
de s'occuper de ses abeilles leur miel
on le retrouve désormais dans une bière
jusqu'à maintenant on fait affaire de
l'hydromel ont livré du miel
hydromellerie qui ne fabrique de
l'hydromel à façon mais en boisson au
miel j'avais jamais rien fait encore
donc maintenant une bière au miel c'est
une étoile de plus dans notre ciel
gastines à l'origine une entreprise
spécialisée dans le tourisme
elle a voulu compléter les circuits
qu'elle proposait déjà dans les vallées
de la cléry de luan et du bet
l'an dernier on avait de nous sur les
basques ont donc au niveau du paddle et
du canoë
lorsque les touristes sortait de deux
lots ils veulent souhaiter se poser et
nous il était hors de question de
ramener des produits de grandes marques
à extérieur de notre territoire donc
nous on avait absolument besoin de
travailler avec du cidre du sirop de
fraises du panier des sergents on veut
vraiment travailler locale en décembre
elle lance ses premières séries en
petites quantités 600 bouteilles à
chaque fois il y a trois bières blondes
deux blanches réalisé à partir du safran
ou du miel de châteaurenard et de ses
environs la tendance elle est allée elle
est quand même au local elle et c'est
évident et est mon cas chaque fois de de
mettre en avant un producteur c'est
quand même c'est quand même essentiel et
ça fait partie du concept vallée
gâtinaise mettre en avant les
les richesses de ce territoire pour
rester dans l'ultra locale
la boisson est fabriquée amis ces
synergies qu'on trouve en faisant un
produit en commun vont vraiment mettre
en valeur tout ce secteur géographique
j'irai on ne reste pas chacun dans notre
coin à faire notre notre métier on
comprend visibilité et donc pour ça
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
intéressant et important pour l'instant
la commercialisation se limite aux
gâtinais est à cinq points de vente
mais si la demande est là les bouteilles
pourraient se retrouver dans des
boutiques orléanaise